oh my god you're so lucky the trans-lux  that was so in right now so in right now  [Music]  what's your really hey do me say this  isn't raka she's been with us for about  a year now I think I could like take  some her testosterone it like get rid of  my period what do you think of Caitlyn  Jenner trans guys are so hot it's like  the best of both worlds so um did he  drag your pretty fur trans woman  it really looks like a real man you just  saw the page oh my wait you got the  surgery can I see your dick no oh my god  you're trans I love gay people I'm not  gay  I'm trans there are two different things  gender and sexuality you have gender  without a sexuality but you can't have  sexuality without gender so I'm trans  and then straight because I gave women  and I'm a man